[Music]
sums up The Morbid questions
so it's a safe space where people ask
brutal things makes me feel better
because it makes me feel oh I'm really
not that crazy of a person okay because
there are Wilder thoughts out there okay
my neighbor pays for our car at most of
our mortgage because my wife farts on
his dick a couple times a week oh my God
no I know a lot of her first comment
from the mod [__] you man yeah [__] you
man
damn it you faked it
I believe this story because farts on
his dick is a really polite way of
putting it yeah but it's also like
really specific like she definitely does
that yeah yeah that's his fetish for
sure getting his dick farted on
oh you're too close yeah don't touch it
yeah I don't want to go in the hole just
fart on it just won't feel the air oh
oh
come on stink here just eating a ton of
broccoli stinky come on do a stinkier
one I know you got one in you
like what
well we became very friends not long
after moving in and my wife has always
been a very very sexual person
one time when we'd all had a few drinks
around his house he started talking
about her Kinks and he let us know his
and how hot he thought her ass was
one thing led to another and now he pays
us nearly a grand a month for her to put
a g string or a thong on get on all
fours and yeah
just fart on his dick a few times
a few times yeah it doesn't finish
huh well yeah you're saying it's a
triple and one
that's three that's three technically
that's the quota
that was one
that was one fart in three different Air
Bursts
our family thinks our jobs pay us a lot
more than they do and I just felt like
letting some strangers know the truth
I have really I hope to God that's real
damn I hope that's real the top comment
does he inhale the fart the guy posting
followed up no he gets behind her like
he's going to [__] her comma laughs
[Laughter]
inhaling a fart through your mouth is is
wild dude
[Laughter]
I mean bro to paint like because he's
peace picking you know I want her to
part on me
so the the booty must be
very specific a specific ass like he
must really
it's like I need this ass to fart on me
it's crazy to like ass
because of the farts it contains you
know what I mean yeah like he likes like
a lot like everyone every dude likes ass
but it's not because it has anything to
do with poop or farts yeah right right
right right yeah yeah right right right
yeah yeah no yeah definitely not Nah
when I see a fat ass I don't think about
it like [__] all over me
I don't know think about this
being turned on by farts is just weird
yeah it's crazy it's an interesting
choice yeah definitely because if you
just want something it's just it's like
anti
sex it's like you're not being touched
you know what I mean at all yeah yeah
it's just gas it's just wind
it's a breeze on your shaft in theory
can you just like open that like oh you
know yeah can you just like cut open
like a durian
what's a durian it's a oh the [__]
stinky ass fruit yeah can you just cut
that open and yeah exactly I mean and
then turn the fan on yeah
same same uh yeah just sensation of a
fan yeah it holds your wiener out to
that get a boner and just stand in front
of it
oh it's like one long fart
[Music]
I guess it is the person it was the
longest part ever that's probably what
the Kink is
it's a person you find attractive doing
something maybe that's a you know a
little bit that's probably what it is
yeah yeah a little bit it's a bit of a
No-No yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
so play like that it's a little faux pas
yeah you can't don't fart in here we're
in public yeah
stop farting yeah
this is not a place for a lady to pass
wind oh my gosh but I just oh this Taco
Bell is just
stop it this has to be a PornHub
category yeah yeah for sure a girl farts
in public for 20 minutes yeah
I told you not to eat that second
burrito dude that's such easy that's
easy money yeah just get the fart
machine with the remote yeah yeah bro
you just get a sound designer yeah yeah
hire a sound designer yeah yeah
yo man so we need to like we go through
a couple different locations we start uh
we start in a Cracker Barrel
so keep in mind we're in a booth all
right so it's going to be more of a
muted tone
they're against the leather cheeks to
you know leather Booth leather so keep
that in mind and then uh we we go ahead
and head out she lets she lets a few rip
in the car yeah um this is a 1998 Camry
so the cabin really it's not that
soundproof yeah all right so we're gonna
need a little Reverb going on here the
the tough one is uh we then went on a
hike
and uh capturing farts on a hike is
you know it's no it's nowhere for the
sound so they're not even farting
they're just editing them in yeah yeah
that's what I mean it's like he's giving
notes yeah and sound designer is like ah
I think I got I think I have a I think I
can tacos this one
[Laughter]
hahaha
oh yes
yes it's one library of fat
I would have gone fat in nature myself
I have plenty of fats
over the years I have such an extensive
library of
gas recorded my own thoughts
for many years
ASMR farts yeah play it let it rip gang
we haven't actually joked about farts in
a lot
what
dude that's
diarrhea yeah what the [__] was that it
was a fart
who farts like this
oh that's a good one that was a good one
[Music]
[Laughter]
have you seen the dude on Tick Tock that
sits on the bed and like orders pizza
and then farts dude can you can we find
that somehow
hi uh yeah hi sorry I'm driving hi
[Laughter]
uh
can I
hi can I please order please
do you have any specials today
okay
it's so funny you like can't control
them replay the first one hi hi hi
[Laughter]
he's like torn between putting it down
and putting into his mouth oh [__] oh
wait uh hi ah
yeah bro
all right well that's it
let's just end it oh if we ended it
right there on a huge fart well that's
it